the two others who were injured in the
shooting eight year old Noah de Haan and
her uncle al mug parrots are telling
their stories
Jonathan Vigliotti spoke with them he's
in Poway outside of a memorial to the
victims Jonathan good morning and good
morning Anthony just before this attack
this synagogue was packed with people of
all ages including children when that
gunfire erupted one man sprung into
action running back and forth whisking
kids to safety but he couldn't get to
his young niece in time I spoke with her
she tells me she hid by herself watching
this terror unfold Noah de haan and her
uncle were inside Habana pal way when
the barrage of gunfire began I knew that
something wrong wasn't adding up to me I
heard a loud sound the eight-year-old
watched the entire shooting unfold
I saw the rabbi's like he was getting
him know his uncle all my parents says
he led the children away from danger
they go to the buck and they put all the
kids for the inside the house we say the
woman Peretz was shot in the leg while
trying to protect his niece Noah
suffered shrapnel wounds to her leg and
her face I also got shot from the chap
yeah retinol a word you said not now
yeah I wanted to help at the same time
but I had to run you thought about
saving somebody when you heard those
gunshots and you also thought about
death the young girl also witnessed the
final and selfless act by fellow
congregate lori gilbert k as she stepped
between the shooter and rabbi goldstein
the last thing she panted he the rabbi
that's what you do she went from the
rama instead of the rabbi dying shooting
the 60 year-old was described as a
warrior of love who wanted everyone to
stand up to hate something ain't
year-old Noah intends to fulfill you're
way too young to be worrying about this
kind of hate
you don't have to go through any any age
any time because you're supposed to like
live life not supposed to live hate are
you going to be afraid to go back to
this in about I'm probably gonna be
afraid but I'm still gonna go I'm
probably just gonna watch out for
anything again she was just eight years
old I was struck by how strong she is
Laura Kay the woman who was killed in
this attack was actually here at the
synagogue saying a prayer for her mother
who recently passed away we're told that
her husband was there and tried to
resuscitate her but fainted from the
trauma a growing memorial has been set
up here in her honor
Norah I know I couldn't get over that
story either about him trying to revive
his own wife and noia strength Jonathan
thank you